SESSION.
I WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE TODAY IS
SELLING MEMBER DEVON MATHIS
HISTORY PLACE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL PEROT ON
COMMITTEE TODAY MONDAY JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH HEARING ONLY --
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM SEVEN
SP FIFTEEN OH AIN'T --
CORPORATE TAXATION VOLUNTARY
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS QUALIFIED
ENTITIES WITH AMENDMENTS.
SO WITH THAT.
FILE ITEM ONE S. B. [inaudible]
TWO TWO SEVEN SENATE.
WE'RE ACTING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL HE GETS MORE MEMBERS BUT
CENTER DAILY ON WHAT YOU.
FIGURE MUCH --
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
IN ABSENCE JUST --
MISTURA.
VICE CHAIR I KNOW MISTER.
VON MATHIS IS HERE AND
SUBSTITUTED BY SEVERAL ONE THANK
YOU WATCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL --
TWO TWO SEVEN MADAM CHAIR --
COLLEAGUES AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY --
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS OF FORTY
FIVE YEARS SINCE I WENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT IF YOU
STAFF MEMBERS.
AND THERE ARE GOOD WORK.
AS YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR
MISPLACED YOUR REPUBLICANS LAST
JUNE WASHINGTON RUSH TO PASS A
GROSSLY IRRESPONSIBLE TAX PLAN
AND CORPORATIONS MORE THAN A ONE
TRILLION DOLLAR.
TAX BREAK AT OUR EXPENSE.
THIS TAX SCAM DELIBERATELY
TARGETS AMERICANS IN BLUE STATES
IT QUITE FRANKLY DUE TO VOTE FOR
DONALD J. TRUMP.
NICK COULD CAUSE CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY --
COULD COST CALIFORNIANS.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FACT THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
ACROSS THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
DEDUCTED OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THEIR STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES SALT --
ON A FEDERAL RETURNS OF LAST
YEAR.
NOW THAT DEDUCTION IS CAPPED AT
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT IS A
HARD CAP NOT A FLOOR BUT A HEART
CAT MEANING THAT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
WILL LOSE OUT ON THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
VALUABLE DEDUCTIONS EACH YEAR ON
THEIR FEDERAL TAXES.
SENATE BILL TWO TWO SEVEN IS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS
DON'T HAVE.
A FOOT THE BILL FOR THIS
RIDICULOUS TAX GIVEAWAY BY
GIVING THEM A CHARVEL OUTLET
THAT WILL HELP THEM WHILE
HELPING OUR SCHOOLS.
SO THE BILL TO DO SO WOULD
CREATE A FUND THAT TAXPAYERS CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOCAL SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS FUND AND EIGHT IN
EXCHANGE RECEIVE A REDUCTION IN
THEIR STATE TAXES.
THAT FUND WOULD BE MANAGED AND
ITS RESOURCES ALLOCATED BY THE
FISCAL CRISIS MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM.
AND INDEPENDENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY.
THE CREDIT POLL WOULD BE LIMITED
TO FORTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FISCAL YEAR AND EACH FISCAL YEAR
THEREAFTER.
THE CREDIT WOULD BE HONORED AT
85% IT WOULD BE VERY CLEAR 85%
THE RITUAL LANGUAGE --
WHEN THE BILL WAS IN THE SENATE
WAS 1100% IT'S AT 85% AND EVERY
DOLLAR CONTRIBUTE TO THE FUND?
THEN RELYING ON LONG STANDING
FEDERAL CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTION
RULES ONE MEASURE THAT I WROTE
IT'S CODIFIED STATUTORY LAW WITH
REGARD TO DEALING WITH CAL
GRANTS ITS CREDIT AT FIFTY CENTS
THIS ONE'S AT EIGHTY FIVE CENTS
WHICH IS LAW OF THE LAND IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT TAXPAYER CAN DEDUCT THE
AMOUNT LISTED ON THERE SIR
CERTIFICATION FROM THE FEDERAL
TAXES.
EXACTLY AS THEY WOULD HAVE UNDER
UNDER STATE AND LOCAL TAX
DEDUCTION ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS
CAPPED.
WE ALSO HAVE A CUP COMPANION
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT AS CA
THIRTY NINE WHICH PROTECTS ALL
OVER EDUCATION FUNDING FORMULAS.
MAKING SURE WE MEET ALL FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
ADMINISTERING THIS CREDIT.
ULTIMATELY WOULD BENEFIT THE
STATE AND ITS TAXPAYERS IF WE
OFFERED A MENU OF CHARITABLE
OPTIONS SO THEY CAN CHOOSE HOW
THEY WANT TO PUT THEIR CHARBEL --
GIVING TO WORK.
TAKEN TOGETHER WITH YOUR OF BILL.
ONE SEVEN THIS MEASURE AND
ANOTHER MEASURE IT WAS HEAVILY
THIS COMMITTEE WILL REVIEW
SOMETIME NEXT WEEK WHICH IS S.
B..
FIVE THIRTY NINE WILL OFFER
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS THE MENU OF
OPTIONS HELPING THEM GIVE TO THE
CAUSE OF THEIR CHOICE BY DOING
SO WE WILL ALLOW.
THE TAXPAYERS A CALL FOR YOU TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BETTERMENT OF
OUR STATE HELPING CALIFORNIA'S
WHILE THEY HELP THEMSELVES THIS
MEASURE WILL PROTECT OVER THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
WITH THAT.
MANAGER MISTER VICE CHAIR OUR
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIRK
STARK ON THE LAW PROFESSOR UCLA --
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY A FEW
THINGS ABOUT THIS --
BILL --
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THIRTY THREE
STATES AND OVER ONE HUNDRED
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
OFFER CHARITABLE TAX CREDITS --
IN SUPPORT OF ONE TYPE OF
PROGRAM OR ANOTHER ESTABLISHED
BY.
A STATE GOVERNMENTS OF THESE
PROGRAM.
LIKE -- SP
TWO TWO SEVEN THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE DONORS WITH TAX CREDITS --
SOMETIMES STANGEL --
AS MUCH AS 1100% FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO GOVERNMENT
DESIGNATED FUNDS AND ACTIVITIES.
OF THESE INCLUDE CONSERVATION
EASEMENT GIFTS.
PRIVATE SCHOOL TUITION
SCHOLARSHIPS.
SHELTERS FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
RURAL HOSPITALS A AND MANY OTHER.
A GOVERNMENT SPECIFIED PROGRAMS
AND ACTIVITIES --
AND THESE PROGRAMS ALL REYES --
WHAT TO ME AT LEAST AS A LAW
PROFESSOR IS A VERY INTERESTING --
LEGAL QUESTION.
CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT A TAXPAYER
CAN DEDUCT.
THE FULL AMOUNT OF A DONATION
THAT HAS THE AFFECT OF REDUCING.
HER STATE TAX LIABILITY.
AND FOR THE PAST. ONE HUNDRED
PLUS YEARS.
THE IRS AND THE COURTS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY ALLOWED TAXPAYERS
TO CLAIM A FULL DEDUCTION. FOR
THE AMOUNT OF THEIR DONATION.
UNDIMINISHED.
BY THE AMOUNT OF THE TAX
BENEFITS ARISING FROM MAKING
THAT GIFT --
SO THE MAJOR VALUE OF SP
[inaudible]
TWO TWO SEVEN ALONG WITH.
AB -- TWO
TWO ONE SEVEN AND THE STATE'S
EXISTING TAX CREDIT.
FOR THE COLLEGE ACCESS TAX
CREDIT FUND FOR CAL GRANTS --
USE. TO PROVIDE DONORS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH CHOICES.
REGARDING HOW TO SUPPORT.
CHARITABLE ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
THE ACTIVITIES OF STATE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
THIS IS CHARACTERISTIC OF ALL
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS --
AND THIS LEGISLATION --
LIKE THESE MANY EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
GIVES TAXPAYERS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. TO SUPPORT
CHARITABLE ACTIVITIES --
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S WORTHY OF
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKERY
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS MEASURE WE
DO UNDERSTAND THE CREATIVITY AND
THAT THE AUTHORS TRYING TO USE
IN ORDER TO TRY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS PROTECTION WOULD COME AT
THE COST OF EDUCATIONAL FUNDING.
AND WE HAVE BEGUN TAKING A VERY
DEEP LOOK AT THIS AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF OTHER MEASURES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS COULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
PROP NINETY EIGHT AND THAT FUNDS
EDUCATION.
OUT WERE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
IN YOUR WERE BEGINNING TO HAVE
AS A POSITIVE TREND MOVING
FORWARD IN EDUCATION FUNDING
THAT WHILE WE'RE GETTING MORE
FUNDING FOR EDUCATION IN THE
BUDGET.
MEASURES SUCH AS THIS COULD NOT
ONLY ON DO ALL THE SIGNIFICANT
THE INCREASES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
EDUCATION FUNDING BUT COULD
ACTUALLY DECIMATED AND A MUCH
GRANDER LEVEL SO WE DON'T
SUPPORT THE MEASURE MOVING
FORWARD WHILE WE DO APPRECIATE
THE ATTEMPT IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING
THAT IS ONLY GOOD FOR TAXPAYERS
ON IS GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
FUTURE TAXPAYERS IF IT'S AT THE
COST OF OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL FUTURE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
SENATOR YOU SAID EARLIER TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE --
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS ARE YOU
WILLING TO TAKE A AN AMENDMENT.
THAT IS GOING TO FOR TAX CUTS
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE IRS IF
THEY COME BACK AND ROLL
[inaudible]
AGAINST THIS.
IF IF I KNOW IT'S BEEN PART OF
THE DEBATE ARMS LIKE OR ARE YOU
ARE YOU WILLING TO TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT TO PROTECT THEM IN
CASE IT COMES BACK.
BECAUSE I MEAN I I THINK THE
LAST THING ANY OF US WANT TO SEE
IS PEOPLE GET.
PENALIZED. FOR SOMETHING AND I
KNOW THEY'RE WORKING ON THIS
RIGHT NOW SO MY CONCERN IS THAT
IT'S A LITTLE PREMATURE --
AND THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD WAIT
AND TELL THEIR IRIS RULINGS DON --
VERSES ROLLING THIS OUT NOW BUT
IF YOU TOOK AN AMENDMENT TO
PROTECT THEM.
YOU KNOW A AGAINST THE NEGATIVE
RULING.
THEN THAT I'D BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT IT BUT MY CONCERN IS
THAT IF IT COMES AYE NEGATIVELY
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON OUR TAXPAYERS
INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY HELPING THEM.
INTERNAL ORGAN HARM THEM
ACTUALLY LIVE WITH I COULDN'T
ACTUALLY FLIP IT AROUND I THINK
RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN TRY THERE'S HARM BEING
DONE TO THE TAXPAYERS WHY NOW IF
THERE'S A NO VOTE.
ON HIS MEASURES ONE BE VERY
CLEAR.
IF THERE IS NO ONE IS MEASURED
THERE'S A VOTE. TO TAX THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT ACROSS
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM WITH YOU
DEMOCRAT ARE POP AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY --
ON THE SENATE SIDE OF CENTERS
CANNELLA AS WELL AS WILK VOTED
YES OF WAS MEASURE.
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER OF THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER OF BEING THE
SPEIGHTS --
MISTER BERRYHILL MISTER GAINES
AS WELL AS LE OF FEW OTHER
REPUBLICS OF TOP MY HEAD I CAN
REMEMBER.
THE OLD IN VOTE NO ON THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THEY KNEW WHAT
THE IMPLICATIONS WORK FOR YOU.
VOTE KNOWN AS MEASURE ACTUALLY
FROM WILL BE VOTING YES TO RAISE
TAXES ON THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
THAT'S ACROSS THE SPECTRUM BUT
WHO IF YOU HAVE ANY LANGUAGE I
WOULDN'T AGREE TO IT OBSCENE
REAL TIME DURING THE COMMITTEE
BUT BE MORE HAPPY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU WITHOUT QUESTION
[inaudible]
ALL THE GOT GOING MORE HAVE DAYS
LONGER.
YOU NOTIFY ME.
AND VICE VERSA BUT WE KNOW HOW
MUCH OF AND WE JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE CAN WE'VE NEVER HAD.
LANGUAGE BROUGHT TO THE
COMMITTEE ON INTIMATE ON
INDEMNIFICATION SO TO BE CLEAR
THAT WAS NOT THE CURRENT
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WERE AND THEY YOU'VE AGREED TO
TAKE HER TO ACCEPT THE FIVE YEAR
SUNSET FOR THE TAX CREDIT.
BUT TAKING AN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE YES AND IN VERY VERY
PRUDENT --
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU CAN USE
OFFER TO US SO WE BUT WILLINGLY
AND AND AND AND HAPPILY ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS DEEMED STATE EARLIER.
YEAH MISTER.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M A
DAMN SURE JUST.
TO ADDRESS THIS CPA'S CONCERN --
IS JUST BILL.
TOUCHES HER PROPOSITION NIGHT
HERE OR CHANGED A MINIMAL --
GUARANTEE ON A PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE MEASURE WOULD
IMPACT PROP NINETY EIGHT WHICH
IS I BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IN SO WE DO BELIEVE
IT CAN HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
NEGATIVE IMPACT IT'S UNCERTAIN
TO TELL EXACTLY.
HOW WITH HUMAN BEHAVIOR IS GOING
TO BE AT THIS TIME TO ASCERTAIN
EXACTLY WHAT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
IS BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT
COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT --
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS FOR POP
NINETY IN EDUCATION MOVING
FORWARD AND I DO WANT TO SPECIFY
THAT WHILE WE DO ENCOURAGE --
I KNOW BUT WE KNOW WE AND
SUPPORT.
AND YOU SET UP --
TAKING PLACE WOOD SALT O. WE
DON'T SUPPORT THAT AS WELL WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SOLUTION DOESN'T DO ANY HARM TO
EDUCATE.
THE SENATOR COULD YOU EXPLAIN
HOW COULD THEY POSSIBLY --
TOUCH THAT PROPOSITION NIKE
BUT LET ME SAY THE FOLLOWING IS
THAT IN A VERY RESPECTFUL OF
OBVIOUS IN A MISS BAKER AND AND
THE THE ORGANIZATION SURE
PRESENTS SOME OF USED TO WORK
THERE ON BUT COME AT AS WE
DRESSES.
THIS THIS TAX CONUNDRUM I WOULD
SAY THAT --
WE HAVE MOVED FORWARD WITH THE
SOLUTION WHICH IS SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS AND
NUMBER THIRTY NINE WHICH WE
BELIEVE WOULD PROTECT.
ANY PROP NINETY EIGHT
EDUCATIONAL FUNDING FORMULAS ARE
BY NO STRETCH OF IMAGINATION
WOULD WE EVER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY TRY TO USURP YOU KNOW
PROP NINETY EIGHT WERE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF PROP.
NINETY EIGHT ALWAYS HAD BEEN A
STRONG SUPPORT PROP NINETY IT
WILL ALWAYS BE STRONG SCORES
NINETY THEN MORE CONTINUES OF
FUNDING --
FOR CHILDREN AT THE LOCAL
ELEAZAR BUT ON THE CITY
CALIFORNIA OF THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE THE COMPANION A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
COMPANION WHICH IS IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT A
NUMBER.
THIRTY NINE BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THAT COMMITTEE THAT PASS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE HERE TODAY IN THE
LANGUAGE TO DO SEVEN BUT THAT'S
A SEPARATE MEASURE THAT GOES
WITH THIS MEASURE.
THAT WOULD PROTECT WE BELIEVE
THE SANCTITY.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND TO BE CLEAR THAT ISSUE IS
WHY IT'S GOING TO EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AFTER THIS.
PROP NINETY EIGHT IS THE REASON
IT'S GOING TO GO TO EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AFTER THAT SO THEY'LL
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONON
THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS IN COMMITTEE.
SEEING AND HEARING AND SENATOR
WOULD LIKE CLOTHES.
FIGURE MUCH --
AMEND CHARGES ONE I THINK YOU
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT A BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE NAY RECYCLING*
WHEN I VOTE.
I WE HAVE A QUORUM SALUTE THEM
CHAIR AND MADAM CHAIR.
I THOUGHT WHO WOULD TAKE THE
WHOLE [inaudible] FOR I I HEAR.
MATHIS [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
GRAY MELENDEZ MULLIN QUIRK HERE
[inaudible]
REAVIS [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
MOVE THE BILL.
IF I ONLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
EDUCATION BURKE.
BURKE AYE GROUP MATHIS NO MATHIS
NO CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY MULLIN LISTS MULLIN
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING VOEPEL.
THE BILL NOW SOME CALL IT NEEDS
TO THAT THOSE ON CALLING NEEDS
TO MANAGER TO GROW MUCH HAVE
GOOD THANK YOU HAVE.
I I AND NUMBER THREE SB TWENTY
NINE CENTER WE KNOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
MOVE THE BILL.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR SECOND OKAY WE WILL BE
BRIEF I THANK YOU FOR SCHEDULING
THIS ITEM AND I I WON I THINK --
I COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
THOUGHTS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE OUR COLLEAGUES AS
YOU KNOW.
ISP TWENTY NINE WILL ENSURE THAT
I I COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA --
USER PROGRAMS I GOTTA GIVE AWAY
FREE MEDICAL CANNABIS OUGHT TO
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE ILL
WHETHER WITH HIV OR CANCER --
OR ANY OTHER NUMBER OF OUR
CONDITIONS THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME --
THEY FOR THE MOST PART STARTED --
DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE AIDS
EPIDEMIC TO PURCHASE OUR
MEDICINE I'M THAT CONTINUED
UNTIL TODAY OP PROP SIXTY FOUR
OUT I THINK INADVERTENTLY UP
PLACES EXCISING CULTIVATION
TAXES ON THESE.
ARE OUR GIVEAWAYS AND ULTIMATELY
THESE ARE PROGRAMS ARE SHUTTING
DOWN -- AND
SO THIS WILL CREATE A PATHWAY
FOR HIS PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE AND
NOT HAVE TO PAY THESE TAXES.
ON I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AYE WITH ME TODAY --
WILL BE BRIEFLY TESTIFYING ON OR
RIDE THE WHOLE COME OF THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE WHO HELPED CRAFT
PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AT GALLAGHER A
CONSTITUENT --
OF MINE AND A FORMER --
COLLECTIVE THOUGHT PATIENT AND
FOREST HEARD OTHER COMPASSIONATE
CARE OPERATOR OF QLOGIC'S
NETWORK I KNOW EACH BE BRIEFLY
SPEAKING AS WE KNOW THERE IS --
SUPPORT IT APPEARS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RODNEY HOKUM
OF THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE HOW
WE'RE ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
ADVANCED --
MEDICAL MARIJUANA AND A
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA
LEGALIZATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES RC FOR
PARTNER DRUG POLICY ACTION I WAS
THE SECOND LARGEST DONOR TO
PROSECUTE FOREIGN IN ADDITION TO
THIS I WE WERE ONE OF THE GROUPS
THAT.
I CONTRIBUTED TO THE DRAFTING OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR I COME TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY NINE WHICH WOULD EXEMPT
CANNABIS COMPASSION CARE
PROGRAMS FROM CULTIVATION AND
EXCISE TAXES.
ON IT IS OUR OPINION THAT THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
AND PURPOSE OF THE PROP SIXTY
FOUR IN AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
FACILITATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
A FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE IN NEED.
UNDER THIS BILL COMPASSION CARE
PROGRAMS WILL BE ABLE TO DONATE
CANNABIS A TO LOW INCOME MEDICAL
PATIENTS AYE WITHOUT HAVING TO
PAY TAXES.
AYE AS CANNABIS NEVER SOLD OR
PURCHASED IN ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS THERE SHOULD BE NO NEED
FOR TAXING THEM.
ALL OTHER ASPECTS OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR WOULD OF COURSE STILL APPLY
UNDER THIS BILL I INCLUDING A
TESTING AND QUALITY CONTROL.
S. B. A TWENTY NINE WOULD
RESOLVE THE AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE
IT'S OP PROP SIXTY FOUR AND GIVE
PATIENTS ACCESS CHU MUCH NEEDED
TREATMENT AUTREMENT THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED.
OTHERS THE NECESSARY FIX THAT
RESOLVE BITE ó PROGRAMS --
OR OF RESTORE VITAL PROGRAMS.
A DIVERSION TO THE ILLICIT
MARKET I THINK YOU OFFER YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HI MY NAME IS IT.
OF ITEMS THAT GALLAGHER.
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M A SENIOR VETERAN AND A LOW
INCOME.
I GOT JUDGE WITH AIDS VIRUS
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND TOTALLY
BLIND AND OR NOT I'VE DEVELOPED
CANCER.
NO OUT OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
SWEETLY WHO HAS PROVIDED
MARIJUANA TO MY HOW TO RAISE.
JORDAN FREE AS ANYTHING IS
PRETTY MUCH KEPT ME ALIVE
[inaudible]
SINCE JANUARY.
ALTHOUGH THE NEW TAX LAWS
PROPOSED PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD FOOD AND
MEDICINE.
AS ALREADY BECAUSE OF THE
COMPASSIONATE CARE THAT I'M
ALIVE.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
WHEN THE SPEAK TODAY I WANT IS
FOR CERTAIN THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CLASSIEST NETWORK --
I STARTED BECAUSE MY SON HAS
LIMITS GESSO SYNDROME A RARE
SEIZURE DISORDER THAT REALLY
KIND OF PAVE THE WAY --
FOR CANNABIS MEDICINE FOR
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITIONS --
WHERE VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION WE
WILL COVER HUNDRED NINETY
FAMILIES AND WE CATER TO
TERMINALLY ILL AND CAST ROUGHLY --
KIDS IN A WAY THAT.
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKETPLACE WHAT WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE ABILITY TO
DEVELOP THESE PROGRAMS WHERE
OTHER STATES HAVE NOT THIS
INTRODUCER.
CANNABIS A REGULATORY STRUCTURES
AND WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO IS
CARE FOR KIDS AND ADULTS WHO
AREN'T ABLE TO MEET.
GET WHAT THEY NEED IN THAT
SYSTEM AND WITH THE SUN SETTING
UP SOME OF THE CAUSES AND S.
BEFORE TWENTY THE COLLECTIVE
MODEL.
A WITH THE EXTENSION OF THE
FEASIBILITY STUDY IS THAT THIS
GAP WERE WERE NOT ABLE TO
FUNCTION AND WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES THAT DEPEND ON THE
SERVICES OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE STATE.
AS I THINK YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS DRIVE OF TODAY.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS RALPH THROUGH
LOVE EVER AGREED [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
SANTA CRUZ [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA PASSING FOLDERS
[inaudible]
SAY.
YEAH DOT BOTH GROUPS URGING AYE
VOTES FOR EVERYONE.
PLEASE LET US CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE MEDICINE [inaudible]
THAT. FOR AND SAVE THE TAXPAYERS
LOTS AND LOTS OF SO.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FROM ARIZONA
SEIU CALIFORNIA.
ORDER THE BILL.
WE GOT A NEW MEMBER BACK
[inaudible]
PAST [inaudible]
USE [inaudible] TWO THOUSAND
THREE THOUSAND WE HAVE COME BACK
REDUCING LOSSES [inaudible]
LIKE.
WE ARE DOING IS GOOD GETTING
[inaudible]
MEDICINE PEOPLE WHO WERE DYING
NUMBER.
SO THIS WILL JUST CONTINUE THAT
EFFORT TO HELP.
AND I'VE BEEN OUT OF CHAIR
MEMBERS HE'S YOUR KIND OF
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR VICE
CHAIR MORE INFORMATION UTAH'S
JOHN.
THE MANAGER MOVES [inaudible]
OPERATION BACK.
THE OTHER ON THE HEALTH OF
AMERICANS [inaudible]
THAT'S AMERICAN AIRLINES
[inaudible]
THE SENIORS [inaudible]
HERE I HI MY NAME IS IDEAL AT
THE PAY I M. --
BUT SHALL DEVELOP BACKGROUND AND
LOCAL AND FOUNDER OF IDEALISTS
ADVOCACY.
MY SO WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
LEUKEMIA EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO AND
SEEN THE AFFECT ON HIS BODY.
UNABLE TO AFFORD THE MEDICATION --
SERVANT OF MINE IN ORDER TO SAVE
MY TO MY SON'S LIFE --
WE COULDN'T AFFORD IT PLEDGES
NETWORK HAVE BEEN A LIFESAVING
RESOURCE FOR OUR FAMILY WE SEEN --
THE BENEFITS IN HIS LAB WORK
ALONG TO WHERE HE'S ABLE TO PLAY
SLEEP GAIN WEIGHT.
AND I AM IN HIGH SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IN THE ACTS THAT --
WE CAN NO LONGER PROFIT OFF OF
THE THICK AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR COMMUNITY.
I DO SUPPORT THE BILL AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME SHAUNA CROOME I HELP
RUN THE WE FOR IS A LOT OF THESE
VETS OUT HERE A CENTER WHERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THIS UP.
RIGHT NOW THE VETERANS ON THE
OUTSIDE LOOKING IN THE CANNABIS
SPACE LEGAL CANADA SPACE
DISABLED VETERANS CAN ONLY
MEDICAID ON THE ILLICIT MARKET.
THAT'S ALL THEY CAN AFFORD THIS
IS GOING TO HELP THEM GET BACK
ON IN READ FRANCHISE --
WITH OUR GOVERNMENT IN GOOD
STANDING THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET OUR DISABLED
THAT'S BACK ON THEIR FEET THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DONNA LOWENTHAL
NATIVE IN NEVADA COUNTY I ALSO
WORK IN NEVADA COUNTY AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE MANAGER OF LAKE
OF THE PINES HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OFSB.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WE NEED TO
OPENLY SUPPORT RECOGNIZE
COMPASSION PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW
FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS RELATED
CHARITIES TO LEGALLY SERVE
CANNABIS.
BARS ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
SUFFERING FROM CATASTROPHIC IN
LIFE THREATENING ILLNESSES FOR
YOUNG AND OLD ALIKE --
ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO CAN
AFFORD THESE THERAPIES SO S. B.
TWENTY NINE PAVE THE PATH TO
HELP PUT PATIENTS BEFORE PROFITS
IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS SEAN AGO KONAR I AM THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF AXIS OF LOVE AS SOUTH WHO.
IS A PAIR ABBASI COMPASSION
PROGRAMS WITH --
HARM REDUCTION SERVING THE
TENDERLOIN MARKET AREA OF SAN
FRANCISCO PER PROBABLY FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AND I WAS ALSO
THE CHAIR.
OF THE PATIENT ABBASI COMMITTEE
OF AYE AYE CITIES TASK FORCE ON
MEDICAL CANNABIS THIS IS VERY
NEEDED I THINK SENATOR WIENER
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK ON SOME
OF THE NOTES NUTS AND BOLTS OF
THIS SUCH AS FEE WAIVERS AND I
TEMPORARY PERMITS.
AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE BECAUSE
OF PATIENTS RIGHT NOW ARE
SITTING IN PAIN AND THAT IS NOT
THE INTENTION OF ANYONE IN THE
CANNABIS COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
HI ANTHONY STORY MF A FIFTY YEAR
VETERAN OF THE DRUG WAR I'VE
FOUGHT THE DRUG WAR FOR FIFTY
YEARS [inaudible]
AND MY DAD WAS WAS KILLED BY THE
POLICE YOU SHOT IN THE BACK AND
THAT WAS PART OF THE DRUG WAR AS
WELL -- AND
I'M HERE HOA.
I'M FROM AXIS OF LOVE AND MY
COUSIN.
I COUNTED YESTERDAY HOW MUCH
MONEY HE SPENT TRYING.
TO MANAGE HEART DISEASE BECAUSE
HE IT WAS GONNA IT WAS SLOWLY
KILLING HIM HAD A HEART A HOLE
IN HIS HEART THAT JUST KEPT
GETTING BIGGER AND BIGGER.
AND HE COUGHED UP A LOT OF BLOOD
ALL THE TIME FOR TEN YEARS HE
WAS COUGHING UP.
SO I'M LIKE GOD AS MUCH AS MUCH
CONCENTRATES AS WE COULD WE HE
SPENT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TEN YEARS.
TRYING TO KNOCKOFF UP AS MUCH
BLOOD YOU KNOW THE CANVAS
STOPPED BLOOD FROM COMING UP SO --
THERE WAS REALLY HARD.
TO IT AFFORDED YOU KNOW AND I
HAD THIS I GOT HALF AS MUCH
MONEY AS HE DID NOT HAVE TO
SPEND SAVED MY SOCIAL SECURITY
CHECK AND I HAVE LYME DISEASE.
AND NO ONE'S TREAT ME FOR THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S A AN ALTERNATIVE
DOCTOR AND IT'S IT'S HELPING BUT
THE CANNABIS HELPS ME.
TOLERATE ALL THESE MEDICINES I
HAVE TO TAKE I'M TAKING A LOT
AIDS DRUGS YOU KNOW FOR THEY
DON'T YOU KNOW AND IT'S TOUGH SO
I'M I'M I'M SHE LIKE A GUINEA
PIG YOU KNOW AND SO.
WE CANNABIS IS HELPING ME.
MANAGE IT YOU KNOW OUT I GET THE
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF SOCIAL
SECURITY AND IN KNOW AYE.
COMPASSION PROGRAMS HAVE REALLY
BEEN MY HAVE SAVED MY LIFE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARK CARRILLO
UNITED STATES MARINE COMBAT
VETERAN --
WITH THE WEEK WHERE PROJECTS TO
SUPPORT HIS BILL YOU SEE A LOT
OF PATIENTS IN THIS ROOM.
DANNY FREE CANNABIS I HAVE TO BE
ABLE GIVE A TOLL FREE.
TAXES EVERY LITTLE COSTS
TRICKLES UP THE TREE DOWN THE
TREE WE CAN DO IT THANK YOU
SENATOR IN YOUR WHOLE STAFFER
PUT THIS TOGETHER THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING SUPPORT.
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY QUESTION
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
HELLO THERESA PUT GUILE EVERITT
I'M A VETERAN DISABLED VETERAN.
I REPRESENT WITH THE WE FOR
WARRIORS --
IT'S BEEN A HELPFUL TO HAVE
COMPASSIONATE --
MEDICINE BECAUSE IT IS VERY HARD.
THEN ON A FIXED INCOME TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IT MEDICINES.
IN ORDER [inaudible] TO TO IN
ORDER TO FEEL.
HE'LL.
AND SO I'M HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE WE FOR YEARS TO
SUPPORT HAS BETWEEN A TONE
ECONOMIC BY.
MY NAME'S WILLIAM BRANHAM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE WEEK FOR WORKERS
PROJECT.
I GET UP EVERY MORNING AND I AM
VERY NAUSEOUS AND I HAVE TO USE
CANNABIS IN THE MORNING BEFORE I
CAN EVEN THE I GOT REALLY REALLY
BAD PAIN.
I GOT ABOUT THREE VERTEBRAE LEFT
THAT ARE STILL GOOD.
IF IT WASN'T FOR CANNABIS I'D BE
FULL OPIATES I'VE TRIED TO
COMMIT SUICIDE THREE TIMES
BECAUSE OF THAT.
ALONE LIVE LIKE THAT ANYMORE SO
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER WINNER FROM
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
BUT HIS SHORT THIS IS A NEED
THIS IS NOT OF ONE THIS IS
INTEGRITY BEFORE PROFITS.
PATIENTS BEFORE PROFITS ARMEN
OWNER.
OUR I NOT ONLY DO MEDICINE FOR
PEOPLE IN NEED COMPASSIONATE
CARE LIKE MYSELF WAS.
AS WELL I DO WHEELCHAIR WHEELS.
PRECIOUS OR ANYWHERE.
I'VE USED IT TO ACCESS THE
BUSINESS TO MAKE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE DISABLED AND NOT
ACCESSIBLE TO GET THE MEDICINE
TO GET THE TANK TO TAKE ME THREE
MONTHS TO GET A WHEELCHAIR WILL.
SOME NOT SCREWED NO MY BUT THE
BACK FROM BACKROOM.
FOR AND I CAN ACTUALLY USE MY
WHEELCHAIR.
THIS COMPASSIONATE CARE THING AS
AS WHAT IT WAS BASED OFF OF WHAT
IS STARTED ON A I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AS FREE I BOW --
I ASK THAT YOU ADHERE TO THE
PUBLIC'S CRY FOR HELP AND HOW
[inaudible]
I THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS I
VIENEN NEWKIRK AND A I AM A
CAMERA MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT
I RECEIVE MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR
MY COMPLEX REGIONAL PAIN
SYNDROME.
ANXIETY AND PHANTOM PAIN AS A
RESULT OF A HIT AND RUN HEAD ON
COLLISION WITH A DRUNK DRIVER
AND CHRISTMAS EVE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE SO I HAD THIS MEDICAL
CANNABIS HELPS GIVE ME A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO THAT I CAN ALSO BE A MOTHER
TO MY TWIN SONS AND BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION WITHOUT BEING IN KIND.
CONSTANT CHRONIC PAIN SO I'M AT
FOR YOU TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
GETTING ARM MEDICINE AND STAYING
HEALTHY AND WELL.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON COLOR THANK
YOU FOR THE FIRST THE BELLY
TWENTY NINE MANY MILITANT OR
TEASE AND THE CHAPTER PRESIDENT
FOR THE SAN JOSE WE FOR YOUR
PROJECT.
I'M A SURVIVOR OF MILITARY
SEXUAL TRAUMA A US NAVY VETERAN.
AND I RELY ON MEDICAL CANNABIS.
FOR MY ANXIETY DISORDER AND
WITHOUT IT I AM I WOULD BE ON
THE MEDICATIONS THAT THE VA.
WOULD WANT ME TO TAKE SUCH AS
SEDATIVES VALIUM XANAX THAT SORT
OF THING WHICH WOULD MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO MY CHILDREN.
AS A SINGLE MOM I RELY ON THE
COMPASSION PROGRAM.
OF THE WEEK FOR YOUR PROJECT AND
AM I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
I MY NAME IS LYNN THE FRIEDMAN
I'VE RUN THE SHELTER PROJECT FOR
JEDI EXTRACTED EXTRACT IS A
LICENSE BOWL MEDICALLY AND
RECREATIONAL.
RECKLESS --
MANUFACTURE AND WE HAVE BEEN
RUNNING FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS --
SHELL THE PROJECT WHICH IS A NOT
FOR PROFIT PROGRAM WHERE WE
PROVIDE FREE --
PHARMACEUTICAL GRADE MEDICAL
PRODUCTS LOVE OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO PATIENTS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE REACH OUT OVER A
THOUSAND PATIENTS.
WHO REALLY RELY ON THIS NO
MATTER WHAT THEIR FINANCIAL
BACKING IS LIKE IT WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH CHEMOTHERAPY AND
RADIATION ALL THAT STUFF?
ALL THE MONEY GOES DOWN THE
DRAIN IN THESE PEOPLE LITERALLY
ARE BEDRIDDEN AND CANNOT GET OUT
OF BED AND THIS CANNABIS AND THE
COMPASSION THAT WOULD GIVE THEM.
REALLY CHANGE OUR LIVES THERE
WAS REALLY REALLY CHANGE OUR
LIVELIHOOD AND IT'S SUPER URGENT
THAT WE PROCESS BE. TWENTY NINE
SO THAT WE CAN CAN I THINK THESE
PEOPLE.
HAVE BEEN ALIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S GREG CRIMINALLY OF
HONG SEVENTY ONE YEARS OLD AND
I'M ONE OF THE UP PATIENTS AND
NOT BENEFICIARIES OF JETTIES
WONDERFUL PROGRAM AND I'LL.
TELL YOU A JEDI US PROGRAM DOES
FOR ME -- IT
PROVIDES ME --
ENOUGH MEDICATION EACH MONTH
THAT I CAN TREAT OF MY PROSTATE
CANCER ON MY ANXIETY --
AND ALSO UP NOW HOLISM --
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
AW THAT'S BEEN ON SHORE A JEDI
HAS BEEN SCRAMBLING TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM AROUND BUT IT'S DATA
THEY KIND OF A THING AND THAT
HIS ON REALLY RAISED MY ANXIETY
LEVEL I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
THAT THE SENATORS MAKING AND
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY RANGEL
I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF THE EAST
BAY HEALING ALLIANCE OF FIVE OH
ONE C. FOUR ORGANIZATION WHOSE
ONE OF OUR PROGRAMS IS CANNABIS
COMPASSION.
THE STATE AS IT IS WITH
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR PASSING
STANDS TO MAKE AMENDS AMOUNTS OF
TAX REVENUE FROM BOTH THE
MEDICAL AND THE RECREATIONAL
MARKETS.
COMPASSION PROGRAMS ARE A VITAL
PART OF CREATING MORE TAX
REVENUE.
IN ADDITION TO JUST GETTING
PEOPLE CURED GETTING I'M FEELING
BETTER MAKING IT SO THEY'RE ABLE
TO BE WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
WERE ALSO GIVEN THE PEOPLE THE
ABILITY TO GO BACK TO WORK.
I KNOW THIS ME SEEM LIKE A
STRETCH STONE IS GOING TO WORK
BUT FOR ME AS AN EXAMPLE I AM I
WAS IN A CAR CRASH IN TWENTY TEN
THAT DESTROYED 0% OF MY BRAIN.
I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
WALK TALK OR EVEN FEED MYSELF
SERIAL.
I CURRENTLY FOR MY DAY JOB BUILD
SEMICONDUCTORS WITH CONTRACT TO
THE U. S. ARMY.
IF PEOPLE LIKE ME WITH THE
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF TRAUMA COMMUTE
BROUGHT BACK WITH USING NOTHING
BUT CANNABIS.
WE SHOULD GET BACK TO EVERYBODY
AND TO PROMOTE BACK TOWARD.
I AM MANY.
MY NAME'S EVA.
HI MY NAME'S IT IN THESE THINGS.
AND A I AM NINE YEARS OLDS. FOUR
YEARS AGO MY MOM.
WAS TOLD THAT THE DOCTORS
COULDN'T HOLD HER AND THAT SHE
WAS GOING TO DIE FROM CANCER
LIKELY SHE WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE PROGRAM.
THOUGHT ALL THE MEDICINE SHE
NEEDED FOR FREE THAT'S WHY
SPECIAL PROGRAMS NEED TO BE OPEN
TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THINK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CHRIS SPARSITY AND I'M
A MEMBER OF REACH WARRIORS.
MUSCLE CANCER SURVIVOR.
AND AS A LOT OF PATIENTS ANSWERS
NATURE SUPPORT NEAR HELP
INTERVAL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RYAN PULL AND ARE
YOU A US ARMY JAG CORPS I AM
ALSO A DISABLED VETERAN AND PART
OF THE BEFORE HIS PROJECT.
I REPRESENT THE AT RISK OF BEING
HOMELESS ARE HOMELESS VETERANS.
AND THE VETERANS THEIR COMMITTED
SUICIDE EVERYDAY [inaudible]
THINKING.
HI ELLEN COMPLICATE WILL FORTY
NORMAL WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS
SOLD TO THE ELECTORATE THAT IT
WOULD NOT INTERFERE WITH MEDICAL
RIGHTS IN ANY WAY IN THIS I
THINK IS AN ADVERT INADVERTENT
THING THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
THESE PATIENTS IN THIS BILL
CANNOT WAIT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN DOLLARS
ARIAL AND I AM THE FOUNDER OF
THE MUNCHING MOVEMENT --
WE PROVIDE CANNABIS TO HOMELESS
PATIENTS AND I'M HERE BECAUSE
I'M I WAS A TWENTY THREE YEAR
OLD DRUG ADDICT --
pSAVED MY LIFE SO I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU.
SORRY MESS WITH US AGAIN --
HERE HAVE AMY JENKINS NOW THE
CALL FOR HIM IT'S INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SURE GETS YOU CAN
MAKE IT TO START UP AND SAID MP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STILL
SCHAEFER ON COUNCIL FOR WHEAT
FOR WARRIOR ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPASSION COALITION.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND PLEASE PASS THIS
WE NEED THIS DESPERATELY THANK.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOEL GARCIA I'M
FROM OF VALLEJO CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M WITH THE BAY AREA
CANNABIS EDUCATION FOUNDATION --
AND I AM A PATIENT ADVOCATE AND
EDUCATOR --
DE COMPASSION PROGRAMS ARE.
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND VALLEJO
WHICH IS AN ECONOMICALLY
DEPRESSED --
TOWN WITH A LOT OF PATIENCE THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO AFFORD THEIR
MEDICATIONS --
AND HALF OF THE PATIENTS THAT
ARE TRYING TO GET COMPASSION ARE
NOT TRYING TO GET HIGH AT ALL --
THERE'S NUMBER OF PRODUCTS THAT
ARE DESIGNED --
SPECIFICALLY TO NOT GET YOU HIGH
BUT TO HELP YOU WITH DIFFERENT
AILMENTS --
I MYSELF ONE OF THESE PATIENTS
FROM A LAUNDRY LIST OF
CONDITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
DIABETES --
LUCKILY I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
BY FOR THE MOST PART BUT I SEE
MY FELLOW RESIDENTS.
FELLOW PATIENTS --
SUFFERING WITHOUT MEDICATION AND
THAT'S NOT --
WHAT -- PROP
SIXTY FOUR WAS DESIGNED TO DO
WASN'T TRYING TO TAKE ANYTHING
AWAY FROM ANYBODY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT HAS SO PLEASE
HAVE COMPASSION IN YOUR HEARTS --
BE REASONABLE AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE SENATE BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHELLY HOFFMAN AND
I I'M FOUND TIME CAMPUS TO BE
HELPFUL AFTER BEING FIFTY ONE
FIFTIES ON A PSYCHOSIS AFTER A
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AFTER EDUCATING MYSELF ON THE
SCIENCE BEHIND.
OUR ENDOCANNABINOID SYSTEM
THROUGH KAISER REHABILITATION
CENTER DIDN'T TEACH ME ABOUT IT
BUT THEY TALKING ABOUT RECEPTORS
AND I MYSELF INSTINCT
INSTINCTIVELY FELT THE HEALING
BENEFITS OF CANNABIS.
AND PURSUED A THE AVENUE OF
CANNABIS IS HEALING.
AFTER --
NETWORKING IN GETTING MY FIRST
RECOMMENDATION I ALSO BEGIN
WORKING WITH DOCTOR VASSAR A
DOCTOR IN GRASS VALLEY
CALIFORNIA WHO DOES MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATIONS.
I WITNESSED ON SEVERAL ACCOUNTS
PATIENTS THAT DEPEND ON THIS
MEDICINE.
RANGING FROM CANCERS TO
AUTOIMMUNE DISEASES.
OF PTSD.
TO CANCERS AND OF THE ONE THING
THAT I CAN SAY IS THAT.
DEALING WITH DONATIONS.
ELIMINATES THE RISK OF CRIME.
AND BEING A FEMALE IN THE CAR AT
BEING A FEMALE CULTIVATOR IS
IMPORTANT FIRST PROTECT HERSELF
SAYS PATIENTS AND RECOGNIZE.
THE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY FROM THE
PATIENT.
I URGE YOU TO PASS THIS BILL AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF IT THINKING.
HI MY NAME IS CHELSEA CAC I HAIL
FROM SAN LEANDRO CALIFORNIA AND
I CURRENTLY WORK AT CANNABIS
BUYERS CLUB OF BERKELEY AS AN
INVENTORY COORDINATOR.
UP BUT I AM HERE TODAY IN THE
CAPACITY OF A CARETAKER.
MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY FROM
CANCER TWO YEARS AGO --
AND ANYBODY WHO HAS EVER BEEN
THROUGH WITH THE DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCE OF BEING A CARETAKER
TO A DYING PARENT.
IT IS NOT AN EASY ROAD.
I'M CANNABIS OFFERED MY MOTHER
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL RELIEF IN
THE LAST YEAR OF HER LIFE.
EVEN BEFORE PROP SIXTY FOUR
CANNABIS WITH A COSTLY HEALTH
SUPPLEMENT AND CANCER
FINANCIALLY CRIPPLED MY MOTHER.
MY MOTHER'S --
IF MY MOTHER WERE STILL ALIVE
AFTER PROPS SIXTY FOUR AND WAS
HAVING TO BUY MEDI MEDICINE WITH
THE EAST OUTRAGEOUS TAXES.
AND WASN'T EVEN.
ABLE TO BE SUPPORTED BY THE
COMPASSION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING SO MANY PATIENTS THAT
ARE STILL ALIVE AND STILL
FIGHTING TODAY.
I'M SHE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THE MEDICINE HERSELF.
AND IF MY MOTHER WAS ALIVE TODAY
I WOULD BE IN HERE FIGHTING FOR
HER RIGHT TO HAVE AFFORDABLE.
COST EFFECTIVE MEDICINE IF NOT
FREE MEDICINE PROVIDED BY THESE
COMPRESSION PROGRAMS --
I AM THANKFUL TO SENATOR WIENER
AND OF COURSE ALL OF THE
WARRIORS OF THE CANNABIS
COMMUNITY FOR WRITING THIS BILL
AND I SUPPORT IT AND I HOPE YOU
ALL DO.
TO THANK YOU SENATOR AND
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IS TONY GOALS I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS.
I AM ALSO A FORMER DIRECTOR OF A
COMPASSION PROGRAM AND LONGTIME
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THE
COMPASSION SHOULD BE AT THE
CORNERSTONE OF OUR INDUSTRY --
COMPASSION CLUB LIKE THE WHEN
DENNIS PERUN RAN AND AS SAN
FRANCISCO PAVE THE WAY FOR PROP --
TWO FIFTEEN COMPASSION PROGRAM
HEARD LITERALLY SAVING LIVES AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HEY COULD HAVE SEEN EVERYONE MY
NAME IS JOSEPHINE VOTERS ARE.
I AM A THIRTY FIVE YEAR OF
POSTAL WORKER MY AS MEANS OF
VIETNAM VET.
AND USE A RETIRED POSTAL WORKER
FOR THIRTY HERE'S I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT.
OUR SON THE FOUNDER OF MUNCHING
MOVEMENT.
THEY'RE REACHING OUT TO THE
HOMELESS IN THE FETAL.
AND IN FACT I I GAVE HIM MY
STILL LEAVE SYDNEY.
BUT ONE ONE THING I WANTED TO
SHARE WAS.
I WASN'T SO OF NOT AGAINST IT
WOULD THEIR CANNABIS.
BUT UPON WATCHING THESE VIDEOS
SO -- ALL
THESE HOMELESS --
TELLING THEIR STORIES THEIR
MEDICAL.
SITUATIONS LIKE --
NOT BEING ABLE TO SLEEP AT NIGHT
OR SCARED OF THE DARK AND ALL
THAT [inaudible]
AND WITH.
HIM BEING ABLE.
TO UP GIVE THEM CANNABIS THEY'RE
ABLE TO AT LEAST HAVE A PEACE
MUFFLED NIGHT.
IN A FEW DAYS IN A WEEK.
ARM WHEN WE SPEND THANKSGIVING
ó MY SON CHOSE TO HAVE
THANKSGIVING.
I THEN ENCAMPMENT IN BERKELEY.
ONE THING THAT REALLY TOUCH ME
WHERE THE HOMELESS COMING UP TO
ALL THE SMILING SO I MEAN
THERE'S PROBABLY ABOUT. FORTY
COLLEGE STUDENTS OR
PROFESSIONALS.
THAT WERE HELPING OUT.
I SAW PARENTS BRING SUIT YOU
KNOW -- KIDS
BRING TO SIR IT'S AND ALL THAT.
BUT THE HOMELESS WERE --
SO GRATEFUL.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THAT SAYING OUR
OWN NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND.
SO THAT MUCH MOVEMENT IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT KNOW WHOLENESS
LEFT BEHIND AND FORGOTTEN.
SO WE'VE YOUR VOTE HERE AYE VOTE
I THINK MY SON WILL BE ABLE.
TO HELP THEM MORE.
LIKE HAVING TO CONNECTED WITH IT
COMMUNITY AND COMPLY WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND A FIGHT THAT
MEDICAL HELP AND ALL THAT SO.
BEING THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELLO
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOSEPH ARONIE AND THE FOUNDER
AND DIRECTOR OF THE SWEET LEAF
COLLECTIVE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN OPERATION
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX IN SAN
FRANCISCO PROVIDING FREE MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO LOW INCOME
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS.
A WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND WE ENCOURAGE AND I
PRO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
ROBERT KERSHAW I'M AND I MEMBER
OF THE WEEK FOR ERRORS AND ALSO --
THEREFORE IT'S BETTER AND AND
WITHOUT COMPASSION CARE --
THE DISEASES THAT I HAVE EVER
RARE BLOOD DISEASE --
COMING VERY WELL OWN UNIT
DEFICIENCY AND PLUS WITH MY
MILITARY INJURIES ON TOP OF THAT
WITH CHRONIC PAIN AND PTSD --
I CAN'T FUNCTION.
WITHOUT THE COMPASSION CARE --
I CAN'T AFFORD IT.
OF THE FED VA DOES NOT PROVIDE
THE MEDICINE THAT I NEED AND
IT'S THE ONLY MEDICINE THAT'S
THAT'S WORKED FOR ME SO FAR HAVE
TRIED LOTS OF MEDICINES.
FOR ALL THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
AND AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT GETS
ME THROUGH THAT --
EACH HAND AND AND ENABLES ME TO
EVEN SHOW UP HERE.
OUTSIDE OF MILES HERE IN MY
SERVICE DOG WHICH IS MY OTHER A
PORTION OF MY MEDICAL TREATMENT
SO.
I ARE STRONGLY.
SUGGESTED I VOTE FOR THIS BILL
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AND
HOUSE AND I'M THE LAN POLICY
ADVISER TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMPASSION COALITION I'M ALSO A
LAWYER AT MACALESTER GARFIELD
AND THE BECAUSE LONG GROUP.
AND I WANT TO COMMEND SENATOR
WIENER FOR HAVING THE COURAGE
AND ALSO THE BAND WITH TO TAKE
ON SUCH A PRESSING ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS SO MANY CALIFORNIANS AS
YOU CAN SEE.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
PARENTS --
CHILDREN OF THE FAMILIES AND THE
VETERANS THAT ARE AFFECTED AND
WHILE ON MANY ISSUES AFFECTING
CANNABIS ARE LESS THAN CLEAR.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IN
OPERATION SINCE THE EARLY
NINETIES WITHOUT HARMING ANYONE
AND EXEMPLARY PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
ALONG WITH THAT SINCE JANUARY
ONE THE ADVOCACY EFFORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN --
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE AT THE
VARIOUS SUBCOMMITTEES FOR THE
FOR THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS IN
ADDITION TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND AND OTHER
PLACES.
AND THE AGENCIES INVOLVED
INCLUDING THE HAS BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL BUT WE ARE AT A
TURNING POINT WE ARE IN MONTH
SIX WERE AT THE END OF MONTH SIX
AND I'VE BEEN TOLD FROM
DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT AUTHORITIES THAT RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF WHERE THE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS ARE FOR
OUR CANNABIS LAWS AND WHERE IT
THIS BILL STANDS THIS IS A
UNIQUE WINDOW A UNIQUE OPENING
AND FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SAID.
AND AND THE REST THAT WILL
FOLLOW I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
STRONGLY CONSIDERING AND URGE
YOU TO GIVE AN AYE VOTE THANK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ABOUT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SPECIFICALLY OFFICE OF CANNABIS
AND SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT [inaudible]
SORRY.
I HAVE BEEN TO BOND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE.
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR DID A LOT OF
THINGS --
WANTING TO DISMANTLE THE
COOPERATIVES.
IN THIS SPIRIT OF THE
COOPERATIVES WAS FREE WE NEED.
FOR MEDICINAL VALUE.
PLEASE PICK MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD.
THESE PATIENTS MADE THANK YOU.
RYM BARGES CEO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GAB IS COALITION AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MINORITY ALLIANCE
BECAUSE HE CHAPTER.
I'M GUYS HAY SHORTLY AS YOU HEAR
MY BREATH ALMOST OUT BUT ONE
THING I WOULD LIKE FOR US TO
REVIEW ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
PERTAINS TO AS TAXES ARE
CONCERNED TAXES ARE MEANT FOR
CONSUMERS NOT FOR PATIENTS.
WHEN YOU GO AND SUBSCRIBE FOR
ANTIBIOTIC OR OVER THE COUNTER
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION YOU DO
NOT PAY A TAX?
YOU PAY A GULP.
SO ONE THING I WANT TO COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR TO REVIEW IS THAT
THESE ARE PATIENTS AND THEY DO
NOT HAVE DESCRIBED TO THE BURDEN
PROPS. FOR PUT IT HUNG THE
CONSUMERS SO PLEASE WITH THAT WE
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL YOU XANDER WIENER THANK YOU
COMMITTEE.
POPPER ALL THE SPACE CAN A
COMPASSION PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS.
I'M A CANCER SURVIVOR WITH A
SEVERE DISABILITY --
HIS LIFE WAS ACTUALLY SAVED MY
COMPASSION.
THERE'S A RARE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO NOT REALLY CORRECT A MISTAKE
BUT JUST CONTINUE WITH BE
COMPASSIONATE USE ACT WITHIN THE
CURRENT LEGAL FRAMEWORK --
BUT OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THESE
TYPICALLY DON'T COME UP THAT
OFTEN-- WE
LOOK FORWARD --
TO SERVING OUR PATIENTS AGAIN IN
THE FUTURE THROUGH THE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK OF COMPASSION THAT YOU
WILL HELP CREATE TODAY --
AGAIN PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
IT'S SAFER THAN THE FOOD WE EAT
ESPECIALLY NOW WITH THE TEST
THAT IT MUST --
WE ONLY WANT TO PROVIDE SAFE
CLEAN TESTED MEDICINE TO OUR
PATIENTS YOUR CONSTITUENTS FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF INCREASING
THE QUALITY OF LIFE IN EASING
THEIR SUFFERING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MY NAME'S KEVIN RICHARDSON THEM
WITH THE WE POURS PROJECT I'M A
VETERAN A MARINE VETERAN AND A
SUICIDE SURVIVOR I WOULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY IF IT WAS NOT FLORA
COMPASSION CANNABIS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ROUGHLY AROUND
TWO MILLION VETERANS WHERE IT
WOULD LEAD THE NATION IN
POPULATION ON VETERANS GLASS ARE
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
LAST STUDY THEY DID.
OVER SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
VETERANS COMMITTED SUICIDE.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE AND THAT'S
HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE ACROSS
THE THE NATION AND VOTING NO ON
THIS IS GOING TO SIGN A LOT MORE
VETERANS DEATH WARRANTS.
I MANEUVERS CREATOR IS AN AYE --
HELP.
GIVE COMPASSIONATE FREE
MEDICATION.
TO PATIENTS IN SAN JOSE'S FROM
AND THE TAXES.
WERE EXCRUCIATING [inaudible]
WE A TEST TO THEM AND IF AND M.
LICENSEE IS ABLE TO HAVE A
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAM I
THINK THAT WOULD BE --
THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC AND I
WOULD BE THE INTENT OF OF THE
COMPASSIONATE USE ACT STE AND I
THINK THAT NOT ONLY.
A OMA LICENSEES BUT RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE FOR
EXAMPLE THE AMERICAN CHURCHES.
ON SHOULD ALSO BE LICENSED --
TO GIVE AWAY COMPASSIONATE CARE
MEDICINE BECAUSE THEY ALREADY DO.
AND THEY AREN'T --
THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY TAXES --
BUT THIS WAY THEIR LEGITIMATE
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS AND
LOOKED AND TREATED EQUAL JUST
LIKE.
YOU KNOW THE REAL M..
LICENSEES IS PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL --
WOULD BE TREATED AND ALREADY
THERE'S A LOT OF SITES LIKE WE'D
MASS THEY ASK FOR WHICH YOU'RE
LESS STATE LICENSE NUMBER WHAT'S
YOUR STATE LICENSE SUMMER BUT
YOU NO FOR EXAMPLE.
A LOT OF CHURCHES THEY DON'T
HAVE A STATE LICENSE NUMBER
BECAUSE THE STATE HAS NOT
REGULATED FOR CHURCHES YET.
OR WILL NOT LICENSE CHURCHES --
FOR A COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAM
OR TO SELL CANNABIS AND I THINK
THAT IT'S JUST A SIGN OF THE
TIMES THAT CHURCHES NOW WANT. TO
SELL CANNABIS AND GIVE IT AWAY
ONLY BECAUSE IT'S LEGAL AND
THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE ALCOHOL
AND IT'S A HEALTHIER ALTERNATIVE
SO FEW.
CAN CONSIDER AND ALSO IN SUPPORT --
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR JASON RIGHT NOW THEY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SELECT GETTING.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND MR AFTER.
SO SO FIRST TO MY FELLOW
VETERANS OUT THERE.
BROTHERS SISTERS I HEAR YEAH I
AM A TWENTY TWO A DAY BAN ON
CENTER I THINK YOUR BILL SPOT ON
IT COVERS A VERY --
YET THE NEEDS TO BE HANDLED AND
I THINK WE NEED.
TO BE VERY CONSIDERING VERY
COMPASSION ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING -- THE
IDEA OF OUR ELDERLY IN ARE THOSE
IN NEED --
ESPECIALLY THOSE ON FIXED
INCOMES HAVING TO PAY A TAX THAT
WAS UNINTENDED --
JUICES THE RIGHT TIME WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM CENTER WE KNOW IT TO
IT BECAUSE I'VE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS AND NOT THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY THERE WAS QUITE A
BIT BUT THIS IS A FOX ON A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR LIVES AND
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AGAIN YOU
WORKING WITH US AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
UC TO REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS IT'S
THEY ARE TO PROVIDE A USE TAX
EXEMPTION IN LIEU OF SALES TAX
AND USE TAX EXEMPTION AT A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET TO THE USE TAX
EXEMPTION STRIKE THE TERM.
INTENDED FOR SALE FROM THE
BILL'S MODIFIED DEFINITION OF
ENTERS THE COMMERCIAL MARKET AND
INCLUDE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
NOTED INCUMBENCY OF THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS.
BEN AND SENATOR SKINNER AS A CO
AUTHOR.
IF THAT WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR BURKE AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS
AYE CHIU.
GRAY MELINDA THIS [inaudible]
MULLIN.
QUIRK ARE QUIRK AYE REAVIS.
PREVIOUS AYE TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RON CHURNING.
MOVING A FILE ITEM.
SIX S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO
SENATOR GALGIANI.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
CAN I ASK THOSE THAT ARE LEAVING
THE ROOM TO PLEASE BE QUIET WE
HAVE OTHER OTHER MEMBERS
SENATORS PRESENTING BOTH AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE TODAY.
SENATOR GALGIANI WHAT DO I DO
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SP TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO WOULD PERMANENTLY
ESTABLISHED THE TASK TAX
RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TEAM.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS TRADE THAT
TRACE TASK FORCE.
THE TRACE TASK FORCE IS A
STATEWIDE MULTI AGENCY EFFORT
THAT FOCUSES ON INVESTIGATING
AND PROSECUTING INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
THE TASK FORCE WHICH ORIGIN MADE
IT AS A PILOT PROGRAM ONLY
CONSISTS OF TWO TEAMS WITH
HEADQUARTERS IN SACRAMENTO.
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTIGATIONS
FROM BAKERSFIELD TO THE OREGON
BORDER AND LOS ANGELES
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SP TWELVE SEVENTY TWO WOULD ADD
THREE ADDITIONAL HEADQUARTERS IN
SAN DIEGO THE BAY AREA AND
FRESNO.
IT'S ESTIMATED THIS THE STATE'S
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS AS LARGE
AS A HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND AS A RESULT
THE STATE LOSES AN ESTIMATED
EIGHT POINT FIVE BILLION IN
CORPORATE PERSONAL AND SALES AND
USE TAXES.
EACH YEAR.
THAT AMOUNT IS EQUIVALENT TO THE
RAINY DAY FUND.
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO IS A
VILE GIVEN THE PERSISTENT AND
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE AND AFFECTS
OF THE ANAGRAM ECONOMY INCLUDING
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS CONSUMER
RISKS UNFAIR COMPETITION AND
LOST TAX REVENUE.
I'D LIKE TO TO THANK THE CHAIR
HER STAFF FOR HELPING ME TO WORK
THROUGH SOME CONCERNS AND
SUGGESTING AMENDMENTS AND I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES. TO
REVIEW THE AGREED UPON COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SHARING OF
CONFIDENTIAL TAX OR FEE
INFORMATION TO MEMBERS OUTSIDE
THE EXECUTIVE BOARD.
THE FOLLOWING SHALL APPLY NUMBER
ONE ONLY PEACE OFFICERS MAY
RECEIVE TAXPAYER INFORMATION.
NUMBER TWO INFORMATION.
SHARED IF IT RELATES WE FELONY
LEVEL TAX EVASION CRIME.
NUMBER THREE PERSONS RECEIVING
THE INFORMATION HAVE A
LEGITIMATE NEED TO KNOW.
NUMBER FOUR NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS ARE REQUIRED FOR
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING THE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
AND NUMBER FIVE EXECUTIVE BOARD
SHALL ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
CONFIDENTIAL TAX AND FEE.
INFORMATION WITH REGARD TO THE
ANNUAL REPORT NUMBER ONE THE
ANNUAL REPORT WILL CONTAIN A
LIST OF AGENCIES THAT RECEIVED
CONFIDENTIAL TAXPAYER
INFORMATION.
NUMBER TO THE ANNUAL REPORT WILL
PROVIDE ALL INSTANCES OF
UNAUTHORIZED OR SUSPECTED
UNAUTHORIZED ACCESS USE AND OR
DISCLOSURE.
OF CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
THE ANNUAL REPORT WILL ALSO
INCLUDE SUCH INSTANCES GOING
BACK TO THE INCEPTION OF TRACE
INCLUDING INCIDENTS THAT WERE
REPORTED TO ANY MEMBER PASSED OR
PRESIDENT PRESENT.
OF TRACE AS REQUIRED BY EMMA YOU.
WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS MARIO DI
BERNARDO ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE TRACE
TASK FORCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BETTER BILL THANK YOU SENATOR
WITNESSES IN SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARIO DIBERNARDO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVE YOU HAVE THE SARAH WHO'S
PROUD TO SPONSOR S. B..
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO A BILL.
TO PERMANENTLY ESTABLISH AND
STRENGTHEN THE TREES TASK FORCE
TO COMBAT THE STATE'S
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA.
HAS A HEAVY TOLL TAKES A HEAVY
TOLL ON HARDWORKING CALIFORNIANS.
WORKERS GO WITHOUT BASIC RIGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
ARE LAW ABIDING BUSINESSES ARE
PUT AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE THREATENED
MOREOVER TAX REVENUES LOSS THAT
COULD OTHERWISE GO TO FIND
EDUCATION.
LAW ENFORCEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES AS CENTER GALGIANI
MENTIONED --
WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT ARE
ESTIMATED.
AT THAT IS LOST AS ON COLLECT
[inaudible]
YEAR.
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD THE WAY ON
CARP COMBATING THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN STATE
AGENCIES JOIN FORCES TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM ESTABLISHING THE
TAX RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE OR TRACE.
OUR CORE PARTNERS INCLUDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD IN THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
TOGETHER WE LEVERAGE OUR
EXPERTISE IN PULL OUR
INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES WE DO
THIS TO COMBAT EGREGIOUS FELONY
LEVEL.
TAX EVASION CRIMES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE.
WE STARTED IN SACRAMENTO AND
THEN EXPANDED TO LOS ANGELES IN
JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS OUR TEAMS
HAVE IDENTIFIED. TWO HUNDRED TEN
MILLION IN UNREPORTED GROSS
RECEIPTS AND FORTY SIX MILLION
AND ASSOCIATED TAX LOSS TO THE
STATE WE'VE RECOVERED MILLIONS
INTACT LOST TAX REVENUES BY
GOING.
AFTER UNSCRUPULOUS BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ENGAGED IN THINGSLIKE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SELLING
COUNTERFEIT GOODS LIKE --
ILLEGAL PHARMACEUTICALS THAT ARE
UNREGULATED --
UNREGULATED BACKHOE PRODUCTS
COSMETICS LIKE OFTENTIMES
CONTAIN HARMFUL INGREDIENTS ARM
THESE FOLKS.
GO THROUGH ELABORATE SCHEMES --
TO ENGAGE AND MASSIVE TAX FRAUD --
BOTH SALES AND INCOME TAX FRAUD
AND THEY'RE ENGAGED IN WAGE
THEFT.
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED WITH
WHAT WITH FIGHTING THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THOUGH SP
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO APPARENTLY
ESTABLISH A TRACE TASK FORCE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THE BILL WOULD GIVE THE TASK
FORCE THE SUPPORT IT NEEDS TO
INVESTIGATE.
THESE CRIMES AND RECOVER THE TAX
REVENUE THAT HELP KEEP.
OUR STATE STRONG WE WITH
STRENGTHENS TEAMS WE HAVE IN
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES AND BUILD
NEW ONES IN SAN DIEGO THE BAY
AREA AND FRESNO.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE TRACE TASK
FORCE TO MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY FIGHT UNDERGROUND
ECONOMIC CRIMES THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE.
THIS WOULD GO A LONG WAYS TO
COLLECTING [inaudible]
STATE.
AND PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
HARDWORKING CALIFORNIANS
EMPLOYEES AND BUSINESS OWNERS
ALIKE -- I
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR THAT THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL WE'VE HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT UP THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS.
HERE I HAVE --
JIM DISK LOOSE IS THE HEAD OF
OUR TREES TASK FORCE WHO'S HERE
TO ASK ANY.
I ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THINK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BETTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF SEMI
WITH CALIFORNIA SICK COUNCIL
LABORS INORDINATELY A SPINNING
GAUGE WITH THE UNDERGONE ECONOMY
EFFORTS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
NOW.
THIS EFFORT TO TRACE RIGHT HERE
ACTION WITH THE JOB THE MORE.
DIDN'T ADD TO THE COFFERS --
AS WAS STATED EARLIER NEAR YOUR
COMMENTS INVITE BY SENEGAL
JOHNNY AS WELL --
THESE ARE REVENUES ARE
COMPLETELY LOST YOU GOT BIZARRE
LIBERTY PAIN THE PRICE FOR ALL
THOSE SICK QUITE FRANKLY ARE NOT
BEING A PRICE.
AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD EFFORT
NOT THEY'RE SETTING UP LOCATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO BE ABLE
TO COMBAT ANYONE ECONOMY I
RESPECTFULLY OR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL LIKE
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
DOES THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER WE ARE
YOUR SUPPORT.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IT OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIR AND READ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AYE
PATROLMAN AYE SHOULD HAVE COME
UP AS SUPPORT BECAUSE WE LIKE
THE BILL.
THE HYPED ALSO SHE SHE LIKES BUT
WE WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR ONE
AMENDMENT A SIMPLE ONE TO ADD
THE CHP THE DEPARTMENT HIGHWAY
PATROL TO THE TRACE TASK FORCE --
I'VE TALKED TO THE STAFF THEY
RESIST THAT I DON'T KNOW WHY.
THE CHP HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN ALL
KINDS OF ISSUING OF WARRANTS AS
RELATES TO THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY --
WE TOOK OVER THE STATE POLICE
FUNCTIONS OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
SO MANY OF THOSE FUNCTIONS ARE
STILL PERFORMED BY SEVERAL
HUNDRED CHP OFFICERS THAT WERE
ALL THE OLD STATE.
POLICE DUTIES --
THEY'VE DONE TAX SEIZURES
ILLICIT THINGS COME ACROSS OUR
BORDERS SOME PEOPLE SMUGGLE IN
TOBACCO ALCOHOL TO AVOID.
TAXES ERA BECAUSE TAXES ARE
HIGHER HERE THAN THEY ARE IN
SOME OF OUR NEIGHBORING STATES
SO WE CAN SIMPLY ASKED.
AND OFFERED TO HAVETHIS HUGE
PAY AS A MEMBER OF THE TRACE
TASK FORCE AND THE STAFF FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND I WANT TO PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO BETRAY HER SPONSOR AND I
RESPECT HER FOR THAT.
SO I'M ASKING FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO OFFER THE AMENDMENT TO ADD
THE CHP TO THE TRACE TASK FORCE.
SO THAT SHE DOESN'T VIOLATE ANY
KIND OF RELATIONSHIP SHE HAS
WITH HER SPONSOR BUT I BELIEVE
IF YOU ASKED HER A QUESTION.
WITCHY WHAT WOULD SHE SAY THE
CHP ADDS VALUE TO EVERYTHING
THEY DO.
AND IF I WERE IN CHARGE IF I
WERE IN CHARGE OF DOJ I WOULD
WELCOME THIS HUGE PEAS
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE THEY'RE
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THERE'S A LOT MORE OF THEM THAN
THERE ARE A LOT FOR SPENT WITHIN
DOJ.
SO MY REQUEST IS THAT SOMEBODY
ON THE COMMITTEE OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT TO ADD THE CHP TO THE
TRACE TASK FORCE.
AND I STARTED LATE I DIDN'T HAVE
A CHANCE TO TALK TO ANYBODY
BECAUSE I WAS TALKING TO THE
AUTHOR.
FIRST AND WE JUST CONCLUDED THAT
YESTERDAY [inaudible]
WELL WAIT.
TELL WILL WAIT TO ADDRESS THAT.
BUT THE AUTHOR.
WELL WAIT WILL WILL WAITING AND
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ADDRESS I
WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND TURNED MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA POOL
AND SPA ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT GOING TO
BE ADDED.
POSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK
[inaudible]
BOB SO.
IT COMMITTEE ASKED FOR AN
AMENDMENT SAYING ONLY LAW
OFFICERS OR POLICE OFFICERS
COULD LOOK AT THE DATA BUT AT
SOME POINT --
DON'T LAWYERS HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE DATA IN ORDER.
TO DETERMINE ARE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A RECENT OR THE
PROSECUTORS SAY WITHIN DOD
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
DON'T THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
ALSO DETERMINE WHETHER THERE'S A
REASON TO PROSECUTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE IT SO THE AGENCY CONSISTS
ARE THE TASK FORCE CONSISTS OF
AN EXECUTIVE BOARD CONSISTING OF
FOUR CORE AGENCIES IN --
THE THREE MAIN TAXING AGENCIES
BEING ONE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BEING THE OTHER.
AND WITHIN THAT EXECUTIVE BOARD --
THOSE AGENCIES CAN SHARE
INFORMATION AND IN FACT AS A AS
THE AGENCY THAT REPRESENTS THESE.
THE DOJ REPRESENTING THESE
AGENCIES IN CORPS WE HAVE THAT
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE WHERE
WERE ABLE.
TO EXAMINE INFORMATION --
AS PART OF THE INVESTIGATION AND
THE PROSECUTION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE DUMB ABDUCTOR
MISTER TING.
THANK YOU MANAGER JUST SOME.
QUESTIONS --
FOR BOTH THE SENATOR AND OR THE
DOJ.
OF RELIGIOUS REVIEWING THE
ANALYSIS.
THEY ANNOUNCED IT HAD A HARD
TIME DISCERNING.
ARM WHAT HAD BEEN DONE ON THIS
ISSUE.
ON WHAT WAS GOING TO BE DONE IN
THE FUTURE I HAD A VERY.
DIFFICULT TIME AS WELL JUST
DISTURBING THE TWO DIFFERENT
ACRONYMS. ONE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY MY FORMER
COLLEAGUE FROM COULD CHALLENGE
LEGISLATION TWENTY THIRTEEN IN
THIS NEW LEGISLATION JUST TORN
UNDERSTAND.
WOULD YOU HAVE ALMOST DONE.
IDENTICAL OVERLAP WITH THE
AGENCIES IN DOING THIS ARE I
THINK THIS ISSUE IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT I
DON'T I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE
SHOULD BE TACKLING.
BUT ON NOT REALLY SURE WHY.
THIS NEW APPROACH.
VERSUS THE OLD APPROACH.
THE SAME AGENCIES JUST IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE.
YOU KNOW WE JUST CHANGE
WARDROBES BUT NOT REALLY GETTING
ANY DIFFERENT RESULTS ATTRACTED
A BETTER STATE OF WHAT'S BEEN
DONE WHAT THE RESULTS ARE IN
[inaudible]
WHY WE?
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
CHANGE.
BUT CIVIC EXCEPT FOR THE ONE
LETTER CHANGE.
ALL FOR OF ALL SAY THAT I'M WHEN
I'M WHEN I STARTED WITH THIS
BILL THE IDEA WAS TO EXPAND
BECAUSE PREVIOUSLY IT HAD BEEN
FOR SACRAMENTO.
AND LOS ANGELES SO WE WANTED TO
MAKE A PERMANENT AND WE WANTED
TO EXPAND IT TO FRESNO AND THE
BAY AREA.
AND SAN DIEGO AND WE PARTNERED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
MYSELF AND AND ALL THAT.
TOMORROW TAKE IT FROM HERE.
DOES SO YOU'RE REFERRING THE
RATES PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY THE TRACE PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED --
TO ESSENTIALLY --
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
INFORMATION SHARING THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED BY RACE BUT BRINGING
THE IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENT --
WITH WITH TRACE AND SO RECOUP
RACE CONSISTED OF THE COR
AGENCIES --
RACE CAME OUT WITH A REPORT THIS
YEAR SUMMARIZING THE PROGRAM
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS IN IN THAT
PROGRAM THEY RECOMMEND THAT
TRACE MOVE FORWARD WHILE RACE
SUNSETS.
I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE TRACE
REALLY PROVED TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT MODEL --
NOT THAT NOT ARE AYE NOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR AROUND WAY
AND REYES WE'RE TRAITS WERE
CREATED BUT WE DO YOU THE
PROGRAM AND THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT ARE --
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEYS
THAT ARE WORKING ON THIS AND WE
SEE THE GOOD WORK THAT IT DOES
[inaudible]
AND WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IT
CONTINUE --
IT'S BROUGHT UP FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN USING EXISTING
RESOURCES IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME IT'S ABOUT FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN COURT ORDERED
RESTITUTION.
WITH THIRTY MILLION PLUS ON THE
HORIZON --
AND WE THINK THAT BY --
STRENGTHENING THE TEAMS IN
SACRAMENTO IN LA AS WELL AS
EXPANDING TO THE OTHER MAJOR
METROPOLITAN REGIONS IN THE
STATE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
HAS DONE EXTENSIVE WORK ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY ISSUED A
REPORT OVER TO UNDER FIFTY PAGES
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS --
WENT THROUGH SOME OF THE
CONFUSION AND CONVOLUTED HISTORY
WITH RACE AND TRACE HIGHLIGHTS
THAT TRACES HAD PROMISING
RESULTS.
AND SHOULD CONTINUE AND IN FACT
THEIR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT IT
SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO EVERYBODY
MAJOR METROPOLITAN AREA IN THE
STATE WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IN THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION'S ACTUALLY SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THAT THANK YOU CRITICIZED HER
ARM.
CONSULTA CLARIFY BECAUSE AND
CARLOS'S ANALYSIS IT WASN'T
CLEAR THAT THAT WAS THERE.
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN YOU JUST
CONFIRM THAT WOULD DEAL JUSTICE
TRUE THAT THE THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS FOR RACE TO
SUNSET AND FOR TREES TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND WHEN THEY'RE IN THEIR IN
THEIR IN THE RACE REPORT.
ARE YOU REFERRING TO THE RATIO
PORT THAT WAS --
AUTHORIZED OR REQUIRED BY A. B.
FI SEVENTY SIX I BELIEVE SO THAT
THE REPORT YOURSELF YES THE RACE
YOU POOR I RECOMMEND THAT TREES
MOVE FORWARD --
BUT THE RATIO POUR ó.
OR WAS SUPPOSED WE'VE WITH
RESPECT TO RACE [inaudible]
NOT TRACE --
TRACE OUR WAS A RECOMMENDATION
WITHIN THE RATIO POOR BUT IT WAS
ODD.
THAT THE TRACE WOULD BE
RECOMMENDED SINCE IT WAS ONLY
FOR THE RACE PROGRAM.
I I'M A TIME CONFUSED WHAT WAS
THE ACTUAL RECOMMENDATION THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT TRACE
PEOPLE WHO HOLD TO FUSE.
FOR NUMBER YEAR SO THIS IS NO
AND NO.
YES THE RECOMMENDATION BY THE
RACE REPORT WAS THAT TRACE MOVE
FORWARD.
BUT WITH IN BUT WITHIN THE RACE
PROGRAM WAS A LISTS FOR A
SEPARATE ENTRANCE OR NO IT WAS
THE RECOMMENDATION THAT TREES
MOVE FORWARD AND THAT RACE BE
SUNSET IT.
THANK YOU AND AND THEN JUST INTO
IN TERMS OF CLAIRE CLARIFYING.
THEM IN TERMS OF TRACE IS IT
YOUR INTENTION BESIDES THE
EXPANSION.
ARM TO CONTINUE JUST THE PROGRAM
AT LARGE WITH --
WITH A LARGER PROGRAM OR IS IT.
WHAT WHAT ADDITIONAL ON
RESOURCES AND NEEDS OR PLANS ARE
THERE WITH THE PROGRAM?
WELL WELL AS YOU CAN IMAGINE --
UNDERGROUND ECONOMIC CRIMES ARE
GONNA DIFFER BY REGION --
BAY AREA CERTAINLY GONNA HAVE
DIFFERENT FACTORS AND AND CRIMES
AND PLAY THEN THEN FRESNO AND SO
I THINK.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THE
SACRAMENTO IN LA TEAMS DIDN'T
COVER THE ENTIRE STATE THEY DID.
ON THEY WERE JUST KIND OF SPREAD
THEN US.
HAVING HEADQUARTERS IN THOSE
DIFFERENT AREAS WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE AB PEOPLE.
THAT CAN SPECIALIZE IN THAT LIKE
BAY AREA YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
LOT OF ISSUES INVOLVING THE POOR
AND INNER MATH INTERNATIONAL
MAIL CENTER --
THAT'S GONNA BE DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT YOU GET IN FRESNO AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
TAILOR ITSELF. TO THE REGION AND
AND REALLY ACT AS A DETERRENT
FOR SOME OF THE BIG MAJOR
UNDERGROUND ECONOMIC CRIMES IN
THAT AREA.
GREAT THANK YOU ON DATA VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE --
SENEGAL JOHNNY FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD ALL WANT ONE OF MY
CONCERNS WITH THE TRACE PROGRAM
AS IT WAS --
MOVING FORWARD WAS THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY IN COMPETITION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROGRAM WHICH WAS
RACE.
IT'S ON GLAD THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO IT TO GET
A CODIFIED BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT WAS ON WITH SOME OF THE
TENSION THAT WAS GOING ON SO.
MOVING FORWARD I THINK IT WOULD
BE ON GOOD TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO
INTERFACE WITH THE AGENCIES THAT
WERE PART OF RACE AND HOW THAT.
ON HOW HOW ARE REALLY IS MORE OF
A COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM THAT
REALLY WASN'T MY IMPRESSION.
LA I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
BUDGET REQUEST THIS YEAR.
THAT I DIDN'T GET FUNDED BECAUSE
OF I BELIEVE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS REGARDING HOW
COLLABORATIVE THIS PROGRAM IS IT
IS CONCERNING THAT MYSTERIES
HERE FROM CH P. AND THAT.
ON THE HOPE IS THAT THE THE
PROGRAM LEARNS FROM SOME OF THE
HISTORYLARA'S TO WORK WITH A
WIDE VARIETY OF AGENCIES ACROSS
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THAT THIS IS TOLD THAT NOTHING
TO DO WITH AN UGLY THE SENATORS --
LEGISLATURE SOLUTION BUT I
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE HAD
INTENTION.
WESTERN AGENCIES TO BE WORKED
WITH -- I
HOPE THAT THAT INTENTION WILL BE
RESPECTED MOVING FORWARD EVEN
THOUGH THE PROGRAM SUNSETS.
ARE BECAUSE I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT HELP SOLVE THIS
ISSUE REALLY BECOME INVOLVED
RATHER THAN.
ON PEOPLE JUST KIND OF GO IT
ALONE.
TIME CAN MAKE ONE COMMENT ON
THAT SURE ON I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
CONVOLUTED HISTORY WITH THIS THE
POLITICAL HISTORY AND WE HAVE AN
ANNUAL REPORT.
ON SECTION OF THE BILL THAT
WHERE YOU WILL HAVE AN
EXPLANATION THE MULTI AGENCY
COLLABORATION --
AND ADJOURNMENTS.
IT'S ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THEY'LL HAVE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OVER THROUGH
THE CLARIFICATION.
A ANY OTHER CAR A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER DE I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
AND YES I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE MOMENT TO RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED --
FAN THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL ARM I'D A MAP WITH THEM
AND I HAVE.
ALSO MET WITH THE DOJ STAFF AND
HAVE CONVEYED A DESIRE AND A
WILLINGNESS.
TO I'M TRYING TO WORK UP SOME
LANGUAGE WHERE WE CAN AND
DEFYING.
PARTICIPATION FROM CHP AT THIS
POINT WE HAVEN'T AGREED UPON
ANYTHING BECAUSE OF THAT THE
LATENESS AND TIME --
BUT CERTAINLY THE WILLINGNESS IS
BARE BUT AT THE SAME TIME I THE
DOJ WISHES TO ENSURE THAT.
THE TASK FORCE MAINTAINS ITS
MEMBER LESSEN ITS FLEXIBILITY
AND IT DOESN'T FIND ITSELF IN A
SITUATION WHERE.
EVERY AGENCY IS INVOLVED EVERY
TYPE OF CASE AND SO I ANTICIPATE
WORKING ON WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO REACH
SOME MUTUALLY AGREEABLE LANGUAGE.
ALMA OVER THE BREAK.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THANK
YOU TO THE AGES OFFICE AND YOUR
OFFICE I KNOW WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THIS WE HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
MAKING SURE THAT THAT
CONFIDENTIAL TAX INFORMATION IS
NOT OVER SHARED AND THAT THE AND
THAT THE APPROPRIATE BODIES ARE
ARE PARTICIPATING AND THAT.
MAYBE NOT EVERYBODY WHO WAS
PARTICIPATING SO THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE CHP
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US TO
MAKE SURE BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
GETS A REPORT AND LIKE I SAID
THE CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION IS
ONLY SHARE WITH THOSE THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO BE SHARED WITH.
WITHOUT --
SANDWICH MICHAEL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE CHIU
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MELINDA'S MULLIN
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING.
TING NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
BILLS ON COLLEAGUES TO THAT
COMPELS ON CALLING NEEDS TO
THINK THINK YOU --
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTEEN SENATOR HILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
[inaudible]
IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D I'D FIRST LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT INC AND
COMMENT GA.
OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN WILL AID
NONPROFIT RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS [inaudible]
THAT PROVIDE [inaudible]
AFFORDABLE HOT.
HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
I THINK YOU FAIR BREVITY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI KATHY VAN AUSTIN REPRESENTING
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION I'M
HERE FOR MY PARTNER RAN MARTIN
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY SO IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME I'M GONNA.
REFER TO MY NOTES.
BUT IN MY COMMITTEE ON ALL DAY
YEAH.
AND SO EIGHT AM EIGHT JOBS --
WHEN THEY STARTED PROVIDING
SERVICES BACK IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THEY
STARTED WITH HOUSING SERVICES --
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
KNOW AS THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES IS THAT.
ONE OF THE MAJOR IMPEDIMENTS TO
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE SERVICES UP
FOR THIS POPULATION IS HOUSING.
AND WHO'S GOTTEN PARTICULAR FOR
THE EXTREMELY LOW IN VERY LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS.
SO H. AFTER SPENT ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
PAST --
SEVERAL YEARS THEY'VE BEEN
PUTTING --
ACQUIRING WE PER PERSON PROP.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE --
VERY LOW INCOME OR OTHERWISE
HOUSING CHALLENGE THAT THAT
COULD BECOME HOMELESS.
AND THIS BILL PROVIDES IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOOL.
BECAUSE THAT TEN MILLION DOLLAR
CAP REALLY DOES THEY'VE ALREADY
EXCEEDED THAT ALLAH AND SO MAKES
IT A VERY CHALLENGING TO PROVIDE
THE THE HOUSING THAT THEY WANT
IS TO PROVIDE AN THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY RAISE MONEY TO PROVIDE.
AND SO BY REMOVING THIS PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION --
SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN WILL HELP
EIGHT H. OFF AS WELL AS OTHERS
TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR THIS.
TARGETED POPULATION.
THINK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AS SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO FIX REACTION I REMEMBER
THINKING REACTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION OF
SILENT CALL THE ROLL COMMISSION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE MATHIS CHIU
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY NOT GRAY AYE MELINDA'S
SMOLAN QUIRK ARE QUIRK AYE
REAVIS.
BEAVIS AYE TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL.
THAT BILLS ON CALLING IT ONE
MORE ABOUT A COMMUNITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND LIVE IN A FILE
ITEM FIVE S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
SENATOR LEYVA WOULD YOU LIKE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT IF
SOMEONE.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE FUND FAXES
THE CHAIR ON THE SLICK
COMMITTEEMAN HOMES LIKE TO MAKE
SURE BAY KNOWS HOW MANY MOBILE
HOMES THEY HAVE.
MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE A THIRTY
SIX MOBILE HOME PARKS IN EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTEEN SPACES IN YOUR
DISTRICT MISTER GRAY YOU ALSO
HAVE A WAY OF EIGHTY FIVE WITH
FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO SPACES.
ARE MISTER BILL QUIRK YOU HAVE
THIRTY THREE WITH 400-400-0100.
EIGHTY SEVEN LOSE YOU ALREADY
KNOW BECAUSE LIKE HIM TO LAST
WEEK PHILIP YOU ONLY HAVE.
THREE WITH THE SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE SPACES [inaudible]
SO.
AND THE REASON I LIKE TO BRING
THAT THERE WAS ATTENTION IS
BECAUSE WE FORGET ABOUT OUR
MOBILE HOME PARK SOMETIMES SO
WITH THAT GOOD AFTERNOON S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD SIMPLY
REINSTATE MOBILE HOME OWNERS AS
ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT PROGRAM THIS MAJOR
WILL HELP TO KEEP LOW INCOME
DISABLED PERSONS AND SENIORS IN
THEIR HOMES.
AT A TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST
FOR MANY SENIORS THE STATE
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM HAS HELPED TO ENSURE
THAT LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS AND
HOUSEHOLD WHO QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM TO NOT LOSE THEIR HOMES
TO A TAX SALE.
DURING THE RECESSION THE PROGRAM
WAS ELIMINATED BUT LATER
REESTABLISHED HOWEVER THE REAL
THREE LEGISLATION DID NOT
INCLUDE MOBILE HOMES.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD HELP
SENIORS AND DISABLED PERSONS WHO
LIVE IN MOBILE HOMES AND ALLOW
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM WHEN THEY HAVE TROUBLE
PAYING THEIR PROPERTY TAXES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR BO WE VICE CHAIR FIONA MA.
I'M HERE SPONSORING THE BILL AND
WE JUST --
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD OFFICE BECAME AWARE
OF THIS ISSUE AND WE HAD A
DISABLED VETERAN WHO FIT THE
CRITERIA FOR THE PARK PROPERTY
TAX POSTPONEMENT PROGRAM.
REACH OUT OUR OFFICE WONDERING
WHY HE COULDN'T BE A PART OF IT
JUST BECAUSE OF THE HOME HE
COULD AFFORD TO LIVE AND SO WE
BROUGHT IT BACK WORK WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO GET TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN SPORT.
WHEN IS IN OPPOSITION?
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
BOTTOM PART OF THANK YOU --
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
WEARING NOT TO SUPPORT IT I
COULD NEVER SHOW MY FACE.
AND NOT MY DISTRICT AGAIN THANK
YOU DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
THEY KILL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT WOULD LIKE CLOSE
ELSEWHERE FILE ITEM I'VE ONLY.
YET.
ONE OKAY IS GONNA FAIR GOING
THAT'S OKAY THIS IF YOU LIKE
ASSEFA BOTH SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'M.
THINKING IS HIGHLY CALDERON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE MATHIS CHIU
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
BLOWING AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
RIVAS.
REALISTS I TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU AND CHAIR THINKING
MEMBERS THINK YOU LIVE IN A FILE
I AM TO S. B. TWO SEVENTY FOUR
SENATOR GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN [inaudible]
WE MOVE THE BELL.
CERI OF A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WELL.
I IT THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO UP
PROVIDE CLARITY OF THE RULES.
FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS ALL THE TO MY
WITNESSES TO ENHANCE THAT BUT IT
ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT IN.
AS THEY WILL MAKE CLEAR SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO RESTORE
MAY REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION FIRST OF
ALL WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR GLACIER FOR CARRYING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL THIS
BILL IS THE PROCESS BILL.
THAT AUTHORIZES THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO COLLECT UNDER THE
NEW FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP AUDIT
RULES OTHERWISE IT WOULD BE
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
CALIFORNIACOULD CONTINUE
COLLECT AND THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY OF REVENUE LOSS.
SECOND OF ALL THIS BILL HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION WE WORKED WITH
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OVER AND
OVER MONTHS AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SOME OF
THE ACCOUNTING FIRMS AND ALSO
TAX ORGANIZATIONS.
HAVE ALSO WORKED AND COME TO
CONSENSUS LANGUAGE LAST BUT NOT
LEAST --
THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE FRANCHISE
TAX SPORTS WORKLOAD AS WELL AS
REDUCE COMPLIANCE COSTS FOR
TAXPAYERS AS A SIMPLE SET OF
RULES THAT COULD APPLY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT COULD BE USED AS
A MODEL STRUCTURE FOR OTHER
STATES WOULD REDUCE THE COST THE
TAXPAYERS WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH. TO THE EXTENT WE HAVE
SIMILAR RULES ACROSS THE FORTY
SIX STATES AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
DIFFERENT SETS OF RULES.
WE ARE CHIU AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THINK THE OTHER WITNESSES AS FOR
FIVE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NIKITA BAY WITH THE
COUNCIL ON STATE TAXATION --
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB UP --
TO SEVENTY FOUR COST HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL WITH
SEVERAL OTHER NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS --
ON THIS ISSUE RATHER WITH
SEVERAL OF SINCE THOSE INCLUDE
THE AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION
STATE AND LOCAL TAX COMMITTEE --
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF THE CA
PA'S INSTITUTE FOR PROFESSIONALS
AND TAXATION TAX EXECUTIVES
INSTITUTE AND THE MASTER LIMITED
PARTNERSHIP ASSOCIATION.
OF THESE GROUPS HAVE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH THE MULTI STATE TAX
COMMISSION ON A MODEL.
STATUTE TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE --
THIS -- IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR COST
BECAUSE THE REPORTING OF FEDERAL
CHANGES IS A VERY DIFFICULT TASK
FOR MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
TAXPAYERS --
IT REQUIRES FOLLOWING A FEDERAL
AUDIT.
TAXPAYERS ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
THOSE CHANGES TO THE STATE'S
THIS IS VERY CHALLENGING AND
TIME CONSUMING.
A SIGNIFICANT COMPLIANCE BURDEN
FOR MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
TAXPAYERS --
THE REASON COST HAS BEEN WORKING
SO LONG AND HARD OVERTWO YEARS
WITH ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS ON A MODEL IS THAT
IT'S IT --
IF WE HAVE A MODEL LANGUAGE.
IT DECREASES THE CLIENTS THE
COMPLIANCE BURDEN AND ACTUALLY
INCREASES ACCURACY AND THE TIME
IN WHICH IT TAKES REPORT THOSE
CHANGES --
THEREFORE COST SUPPORTS SP TWO
SEVENTY FOUR BECAUSE
INCORPORATES MANY OF THE
CONCEPTS IN THE MODEL THAT'S
BEING DEVELOPED AND WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL HELP ACHIEVE
UNIFORMITY AND IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE THANK YOU.
JEFF SERIES ON BEHALF OF THE
MASTER LIMITED PARTNERSHIPS
ASSOCIATION THIS IS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
PUBLICLY TRADED PARTNERSHIPS AND
WE JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ON
THE OTHER PROPONENTS.
FOR RECOGNIZING THE UNIQUENESS
OF THE PUBLICLY TRADED
PARTNERSHIP IN IDENTIFYING SOME
LANGUAGE IN THE BALL THE ALLOWS
IT TO ACCOMPLISH THE SAME GOALS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEN SENATOR WHICH I AM
SURE JUST IN CLOSING I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL
AS THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
COMING UP WITH A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THAT TODAY.
I WANNA THANK GOD ADMITS TO MAY
AND I'M STILL DAY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND AND AND ASK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION WITH AN AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THINK YOU THEIR AMENDMENTS ON
THE AUTHORS AGREE TO TAKE IS A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT LIST ON PAGE
ELEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS WITH THEM
A SILENT COLOR.
OTION REGNANT YES ARE.
YOU PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE MATHIS CHU.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK I
READ THIS.
WE'VE AS I TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
LIVING A FILE ITEM SEVEN SP
FIFTEEN WAIT THAT'S THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WITH AMENDMENTS WAS HAILING FROM
THE WORLD WE NEED --
I NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
SORRY.
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IN FACT IN CHOLERA.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE MATHIS CHIU
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REAVIS REAVIS AYE TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL.
CAN THANK CALENDAR IS OUT MOVING
TO FILE ITEM WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT THE FALLEN FILE ITEM ONE SP
TWO TWO SEVEN CALL THE ABSENTEES
[inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRANO MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THAT GOES OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THREE SB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE ARE WITH THE
COLUMN FILE ITEM THREE SB NEED
TWENTY NINE CALL THE ABSENTEES.
THAT DOES SOUND BOTH GOVERNMENT
LIFTING THE CALL ON FOUR I DON'T
FOR S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTEEN CALL THE
ABSENTEES [inaudible]
MATHIS CHIU [inaudible]
MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I MATHIS I CHIU.
CHIU ARE AYE.
BUT LET'S NOT [inaudible]
HE FINANCE.
BUT BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
WHEN?
ONE AND WE CAN.
LIFTING CALLING FILE ITEM SIX SP
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO GALGIANI CALL
THE ABSENTEES CHIU.
CHU I MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I HAVE BEEN [inaudible]
IS THERE.
LET ME GET IT CORRECTED.
I AM SIX GRAY NOT VOTING TO AYE.
IN THE WEEK.
TO I AM LIVING ADD ONS FILE ITEM
ONE S. B..
TWO TWO SEVEN FINE ON THEM OKAY
WE'RE GOOD FILE ITEM TO S. B..
TWO SEVENTY FOUR CALL ABSENTEES
MATHIS BY MATHIS AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE MELINDA'S VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I CLEARLY IF FILE ITEM.
THREE SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE CALL
THE ABSENTEES.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY NOW MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I LIVING FILE ITEM FIVE
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY LEYVA.
COOLEY ABSENTEES MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE CHU.
CHU AYE MELINDA'S VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I GOOD TO GO.
WAIT A MINUTE LET ME.
SURELY HAVE --
CONSENT CALENDAR OUT WE CAN
THANK CALENDAR [inaudible]
OUNCE [inaudible]
OKAY HOME [inaudible]
HOLD ON IT'S WHAT YOU GET WITH
THEM.
ADDING ONTO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MATHIS.
MATHIS I CHIU [inaudible]
CHIU I VOEPEL.
I BELIEVE I DID.
BUT IT'S A HOLD ON I HAVE
EVERYONE --
SERGEANTS RECALL MISS MELINDA'S
OFFICE AND SEE IF SHE INTENDS TO
COME UNDER GREAT [inaudible]
WONDER WHAT.
BUT LET HIM KNOW HOLD IT
[inaudible]
FOR FIVE OKAY WERE [inaudible]
I HAVE
.
NO NOT YET [inaudible]
AMERICAN.
BARBARA LET'S HOPE WE MEAN THAT
[inaudible]
WHY?
IT NOT I THINK I THINK THAT THIS
SHE SAID SOME OF THE WORLD'S
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
OSHITA.
WE'RE A GOOD CHRISTIAN IS NOT.
BECAUSE OF SO MANY MINUTES AGO
SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY
[inaudible]
ON
WHAT.
AND WITH THE WITH [inaudible]
I WAS.
EVEN AFFECTS THIS [inaudible]
REST
[inaudible] SEVEN IF YOU
[inaudible]
GEN.
NOW A JOURNEY.
JACKSON REV. FIFTY REVENUE AND
TAXATION FRIDAY
[inaudible]
EVER [inaudible]
MADE [inaudible]
NOW.
I GOT THE DATA GATHERED
.
TAKE MY PROP THINK.
NPA